the spectators podcast now have a
newsletter
sign up for free at spectator dot co dot
uk forward slash
podcast dash highlights to get the
spectators podcast highlights in your
inbox
every monday
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
where each week a few of our favorite
writers
read out their articles in the issue
this episode will be joined by over
matthews who reads his cover piece about
how russia plans to unleash
chaos and we'll be joined by lionel
shriver
who picks out on the interesting
similarities between the open letter
and the ransom note and at the very end
peter hitchens who talks about why he'll
be putting his foot down
on wearing a mask during blood donation
first up owen matthews
there's only one person who will be
genuinely pleased with this intelligence
and security committee's russia report
finally revealed on tuesday
and that's vladimir putin russia emerges
as an amorphous and formidable enemy
all the more so because the inconclusive
and much redacted
next report no substantiated allegations
instead russia appears as a phantom
unknowable menace
and this will spawn a thousand
conspiracy theories
far more corrosive and confusing to our
politics
than any moscow generated twitter storm
or document leak
there's no smoking gun on brexit yet the
government-induced delay
in publication allows anyone that way
inclined to imagine a cover-up
even the insistence that the state
should do more to prevent russian
meddling plays into putin's hands
the fear of russian interference in
british elections creates chaos and
division
and this rather than any particular
result is putin's real goal
russia may be reeling from a collapse in
oil prices and one of the highest rates
of covert 19
infection in the world but moscow relies
on pushing the idea that it's the west
that is really in trouble ranked with
violent culture wars
and suffering from a profound loss of
faith in its own values
the kremlin's new party line is we may
have it bad
but their crisis is much worse and where
putin's propagandists lead
its trolls and hackers follow
if recent history is anything to go by
the raging divisions around the black
lives matter movement
are also a sweet spot for russian trolls
set on fanning the flames of the west
self-immolation
in the uk in the eu and especially in
america
a u.s senate intelligence committee
investigation into the 2016
u.s presidential election concluded that
a russian fake news campaign
targeted quotes no single group more
than african americans
end quotes russian operatives used
social media to suppress
black voter turnout and a stoke division
along racial lines
one facebook page the group operated
blacktivist
racked up 11.2 million user engagements
and more than 360 000
likes by september of 2017
compared with the 301 000 likes of the
verified black lives matter facebook
account
russian trolls are equal opportunity
provocateurs
between 2014 and 2017 the internet
research agency
a troll farm based in st petersburg
founded by close putin ally evgeny
brigoyen
run thousands of twitter facebook
instagram and youtube accounts
propagating both
pro-black and pro-southern culture
themes in the us
as well as pro-scottish independence and
brexit-related tweets and posts
a detailed 2018 study by the university
of washington
found that russian-controlled twitter
accounts that mention the hashtag black
lives matter
were disseminating not only pro-blm
messages but also ironic anti-blm memes
such as quotes what is this world coming
to when you can't aim a gun at some cops
without them
shooting you hashtag black lives matter
end quotes and just in case that wasn't
cynical enough
russian trolls even sought to discredit
blm by promoting the message
that quotes black lives matter
is an arm of the russian government end
quote
is the internet research agency still up
to its old tricks
during the latest season of violence and
civil strife that has spread from
america to the uk
most certainly according to seven u.s
officials briefed on the latest
intelligence
who spoke recently to the new york times
and warned
that russia's svr foreign intelligence
agency has stepped up the scale and
sophistication of its efforts to fuel
discord
quotes we see russia is willing to
conduct
more brazen and disruptive influence
operations
because of how it perceives its conflict
with the west end quotes
david porter a top agent in the fbi's
foreign influence task force told an
election security conference in
washington in february
quotes to put it simply russia wants to
watch us
tear ourselves apart end quote
while facebook and twitter have become
more vigilant about fake accounts
the russians have also become much
better at covering their tracks
after technical details of how fake
accounts were spotted emerged during the
congressional investigations
trolls now take care to remove traceable
watermarks from their photographs
and avoid overtly racist language that
gets flagged up by automated systems
rather than use public pages to spread
messages as widely as possible as in
2016
russian operatives are according to the
officials who briefed the new york times
using private facebook groups posts on
the online message board
4chan and closed chat rooms that are
more difficult to monitor
and in a sinister echo of the micro
polling strategies
developed by cambridge analytica these
messages and groups are tightly targeted
on swing voters in swing states
it's no surprise that russia is so good
at influence operations in the west
given how long it's been doing them in
the 1920s and 30s the brilliant
moscow-backed german communist agitator
and networker
willie munsenberg set up and channeled
money
to dozens of front organizations from
the league against imperialism
to workers international relief in order
to draw
thousands of liberal-minded people into
supporting good causes
secretly funded by the communist
international
minsberg called them his innocence clubs
these arms length organizations had much
wider influence than overtly soviet
propaganda organs
such as lumenite or the daily worker
just as today's fake accounts have more
influence than the conspiracy theory
spewing sputnik news agency and the rt
formerly russia today news channel where
it was recently claimed that blm was a
front organization funded by george
soros
in 1927 well before europe had become
the cultural suburb of the us that it is
today
munsenberg's network whipped up global
protests against the execution of a pair
of american anarchists
nicola sacco and bartolomeo vanzetti
convicted for double murder during a
robbery
protests in support of sacco and
vanzetti were held in every major city
in north america
and europe as well as in tokyo sydney
melbourne
sao paulo rio de janeiro buenos aires
montevideo johannesburg auckland
and even by the pearl divers of dubai
after the pair eventually went to the
electric chair just after midnight on
23rd of august 1927
angry riot has destroyed property in
paris london and other european cities
the soviets covertly channeled funds to
the campaign for nuclear disarmament
and to the national union of mine
workers during the 1984 strike
and though fbi director j edgar hoover's
suspicions that martin luther king
was receiving russian funds were
unfounded
soviet propagandists used american
racism to discredit washington's claim
to moral leadership during the cold war
whenever the ussr was criticized for its
human rights abuses
the standard official rebuttal and you
lynch negroes
was so proverbial that it became
shorthand for soviet water baotism
today russian propagandists no longer
have to recruit useful idiots to further
their cause
they can simply speak directly to
millions through social media
and their task is easier than for
earlier generations of influencers
because instead of spreading the message
of communism the modern russian trolls
aim
is a simple reversal of saint francis of
assisi's prayer
to bring discord in place of harmony
error instead of truth and despair where
there is hope
but what is most chilling of all is that
perhaps for the first time since the
great depression
russia's latest divisive interference
comes
in a period where not only the us's
leadership of the free world
but also its faith in itself are
starting to waver
the hostile takeover of the once
moderate u.s republican party by
trumpian nationalists on the right
and the destruction of classical
liberalism by the zealotry of political
correctness on the left
makes america more vulnerable than ever
to the kind of toxic nihilism put out by
the kremlin
brexit and an ongoing crisis in
confidence in the eu
across the continent are also music to
the kremlin's ears
any kind of discord in the west
reinforces putin's fundamental message
to his own people
and to the world that democracy is a
weakness not a strength
vladimir lenin quoting nikolai
childlesski
wrote quotes the worst the better end
quotes
of the collapsing czarist regime the
same is true for putin
the more divided the west is by its own
culture wars
the better his own rule looks in
comparison
putin presiding over a corrupt and
ailing economy
that is just one fifteenth the size of
america's
cannot hope to destroy what the kgb used
to call the main
adversary but russia can help
and certainly is helping america and its
allies
to destroy themselves that was owen
matthews
and now lionel shriver
in the states the open letter is
enjoying quite the formal renaissance
curiously recent examples of this newly
popular epistolary genre
exhibit striking similarities to the
ransom note
during june's riots following george
floyd's murder
a beloved independent bookstore in
denver called the tattered cover
posted online that the shop would be
politically impartial
the better to remain in neutral space
for customers
q local outrage pew the stores
immediate volk foss fulsome support for
black lives matter
the reversal proved unsatisfactory
signed by mifft patrons and authors an
open letter to the owners listed 10
demands
among them the shop must hire more
individuals from marginalized
backgrounds
especially at management level which
would presumably entail sacking existing
staff reconfigure its stock of books to
adequately reflect u.s demographics
donate 10 percent of its paid
promotional space to
minority writers never call the police
when disruptive customers are black
and install a voting empowered board
of relevant community members to control
programming so much for being an
independent
as my brother emailed maybe they should
burn down their own bookstore
in solidarity
meanwhile the chicago-based poetry
foundation expressed formal camaraderie
with the black community
and denounced systemic racism
an open letter decried this statement as
worse than the bare minimum signed by
hundreds of
beneficiaries poets whom the foundation
had awarded grants
and whose publication it had facilitated
the letter listed five demands
these included replace the president
with someone
affirming for people of color disabled
people trans people queer people and
immigrants
drastically diversified staff thus
firing current employees and
redistribute every cent of the
foundation's
massive wealth hoarding directing the
bulk
towards littering work that is
explicitly anti-racist
contemporary poetry can be a slog at the
best of times
teetering stacks of explicitly
anti-racist collections
could kill it for good
however incredibly the poetry foundation
is rich
more incredibly still the shakedown
worked
resignations followed and the promised
one million dollar backhander
is doubtless just the start
now open letters are often blackmailing
if we can use that term
universities online diatribes decry
a school's shabby racial record and
issue the
now standard list of demands
the letter to princeton's provost signed
by
more than 350 of its own faculty
itemized 48 demands some symbolic
statues building names some substantive
more steroidal affirmative action but
the open
letter to stanford takes the biscuit
each crammed with a host of sub demands
the 16
stipulations are distributed under the
headings
within six months within 12 months and
within
18 months signed by a host of
racially exclusive student organizations
such as
the stanford black pre-law society
the document might seem justifiably
urgent were
to request please stop allowing the kkk
to burn crosses on campus
but we're way beyond that
insisting that stanford devote at least
25 million dollars to this purification
ritual
the letter commands the administration
to guarantee a job for one hundred
percent of black postdocs
and to provide two black career
counselors
for every marginalized grad student
this school must not only assist but
finance
black protest movements sorry
non-violent libertary practices
no less than three million dollars must
bankroll
improved quality of life and well-being
for black students
including campus shuttle service to
black spiritual meetings
one black therapist for every five black
grad
students while any non-black therapists
at stanford must complete training to
address
white privilege more on campus
black fitness instructors black owned
restaurants
and black estheticians skilled in caring
for
and styling black hair textures
further annual anti-racism training for
the entire stanford community
must last a minimum of eight hours
and go beyond traditional training i.e
implicit bias and microaggression
any individual reported for acts of
racial injustice
must complete an additional unpaid 40
hours of anti-racist
training as a first warning
as i can't do this extraordinary
document justice masochistic readers
should check out stanford daily.com
calling for wholesale affirmative action
substantially in excess
of minority percentages of the
population
one online comment stressed there is
nothing too extreme
this open letter also has the texture of
a ransom note if
given its prolixity from kidnappers with
time on their hands
implicit then is or else
or else what why doesn't stanford tell
the signatories to stuff their
arm-chancing extortion letter
where most of us stash last night's
dinner
what's baffling about these petitions
for massive transfers of educational
resources
into demonstrably counterproductive
anti-racism training
huge administrative expansions and
levels of personal support for
minorities that no students of any race
are ever offered american universities
are going broke in plague world
lucrative international students are
withdrawing and domestic students are
delaying admission
students depending on funding from state
governments
that are also going broke are in for an
ugly surprise
at stanford hiring is already frozen
discretionary spending forbidden
the poetry foundation's large endowment
makes it a tempting mark
but bookstores closed for months
can't afford to become charities
universities with devastated enrollments
can't lavish
vast sums on racial gesturing
indeed the whole blm movement seems to
be fomenting in a parallel
universe fiddling with white fragility
while rome
burns both the american and british
economies are perched on a precipice
the u.s unemployment rate in june was
more than 12 percent
and with state re-lockdowns that number
could readily
soar beyond april's near 15
for black americans unemployment is
already
more than 15 rather than insist
institutions
feed an opportunistically thriving
anti-racism industry
activists might best save their
continuity for when there's
really something to complain about
they won't have to wait long
that was lionel schreiber and now peter
hitchens
any day now i shall be frog marched or
at least
very firmly escorted out of a blood
donor center
in london i know this is going to happen
because i made the appointment weeks ago
and i intend to keep it but when i
signed up to donate my pint of blood to
the public good
i was not required to wear a muzzle
during my donation
now i am i do not intend to do so
i find the idea of donning one of these
face nappies physically repulsive
and dislike the mouthless submissive
appearance they create in all their
wearers
i also believe them to be futile i know
the government believed this too because
it was saying so
only eight weeks ago and has been no
great scientific discovery since then
but above all i'm severely distressed by
the obligation
i should not be forced into such a
gesture it requires me to ascent to a
stupid and damaging policy of national
panic and self-imposed economic tragedy
i loathe the way we are more and more
expected to silence our dissent but this
new requirement to make a public
declaration of support for the state
by meekly gagging ourselves in public is
actually totalitarian
you're welcome to say that i'm being
selfish but hold on before you get
carried away
i'm not sure how my level of selfishness
is calculated
i'm one of the very small minority about
830 000 in england
who willingly donate blood i've been
doing it on and off since 1970
i often try to persuade others to join
me but i find that people are curiously
reluctant to endure the needle in the
arm and the small but definite risks
involved
if you feel your willingness to wear a
mask is unselfish
that my refusal is selfish and that i
should put up with it in this case
you can easily cancel out the loss of my
contribution
by volunteering yourself and replacing
my lost gore with your own for as long
as this rule lasts
but i know you won't your resolution
will fade when it comes to the tedious
pallava of booking the appointment
turning up filling in the intrusive
forms and then being skillfully stabbed
on the inside of your elbow
it'll be too much trouble so don't call
me selfish
don't accuse me on very thin evidence of
endangering others when i can prove that
my actions have helped to save the lives
of others
instead think about what i am saying
blood donor centers
are not like shops or trains or buses
i'm not asking the owner to let me in as
a favor to him i'm asking to be let in
to do a favor to anyone who might need
a blood transfusion i'll use nothing if
i'm kept out except
the sense of a duty done a cup of tea
and a couple of custard creams
i gain nothing except the tea and
biscuits if i'm allowed in
the owner the government is not running
a business
it's helping me and others in a joint
enterprise of mercy
so the argument that the owner has a
right to refuse if he won't meet his
conditions is pretty weak
also isn't someone who's giving
something away entitled to some say over
the conditions
in which he does it i'll be told that
i'm endangering the staff
but why should i be donor centers are
not places of sickness but places
of health their staff as well as being
among the pleasantest people you're ever
likely to meet
unlike their rigid-minded bosses are
overwhelmingly healthy and young so the
dangers to them from curvid is
statistically tiny
so is the risk that i am a carrier and
other disease is vanishing from among us
in any case not much time is spent in
close proximity
there are a couple of brief interviews
across the table then a short moment
when the needle is inserted
and another when it is removed but i
would have far more contact with any of
the staff if i asked them to come to the
muzzle-free pub
the danger such as it was had presumably
been
much greater back in late april at the
height of the panic when i last gave
blood
and was not required to cover my face
but it is even sillier than that the law
on muzzle wearing does not actually
apply to blood donor centers only to
public transport and now
shops as originally set out in the
health protection coronavirus wearing
face coverings on public transport
england regulations 2020 it allows
several exemptions these used
imaginatively would allow a bit of
discretion for people such as me
if anybody wanted to use discretion nhs
blood and transplant
claims to base its policy on the rules
for hospitals which are not backed by
law and also offer exemptions
when i repeatedly pointed this out to
the english blood agency
they ignored me they stuck to their
rigid prepared concrete headed statement
but that is not all at the time of
writing the welsh blood service is doing
the exact opposite the difference is so
great it makes one
gasp and stretch one's eyes they require
donors to
remove face coverings for safety reasons
they fear such coverings
make it hard for staff to detect the
signs that donors
may be about to faint and so possibly
injure themselves
it is essential that our staff can see
donors faces
so they can intervene at the earliest
opportunity if the donor is about to
faint they explain
we will ask you to remove your face
covering once you enter one of our
screening booths
and then for the rest of your donation
journey they add that they will respect
a donor's decision
not to wear a face covering at any stage
saying rightly that this is a personal
choice
that is roughly what the english service
said until the muslims got hold of them
so unless things change again it looks
as if i shall be headed to wales pretty
soon where they're happy to let me hand
over my crimson harmful
without demanding a declaration of
allegiance to matt hancock
or anyone else getting such a surrender
out of me is well
like getting blood out of stone
that was peter hitchens thanks for
listening to this episode of spectator
out loud
as ever we'd love to hear from you so do
you email in at podcast
spectator dot co dot uk have a nice
weekend and join us again next episode
the spectators podcast now have a
newsletter sign up for
dot free at uk forward slash podcast
dash
highlights to get the spectators podcast
highlights in your inbox every monday